um all
right welcome everybody Welcome
everybody back from lunch so our
afternoon speaker our first afternoon
speaker will be Moses Char car visiting
us from Stanford to talk about sketching
for kernel density
estimation okay thanks everyone for
coming
um I want to try doing a a whiteboard
talk on this one so let's see how this
goes so the problem I want to talk about
is
the Cal evaluation
problem so here's the problem you're
given a data set of
points uh let's say there are n of
them three
dimensional what we have to do is we got
to pre-process these points so as to be
able to answer queries
and what are the queries that we we want
to
answer the queries are points in this
space and given a query we want to
compute the sum um over the data
set the
sum of this so-called kernel
function
for the entire
data okay so there's some function
kpq um think of this as a function that
drops off as you go further and further
away from P so each point in the data
set has some sort of force
field drops off let's say it's symmetric
it's radial it depends only on the
distance it's monotone
um and what we want to know is at the
query q what's the net force from from
the entire data
set we want you want to evaluate this
this
function um so you know let's let's put
some conditions on this on this kind of
thing um we'll say that this is
a
positive
definite radial
so radial just
means um you know the the value in any
direction is the same it just depends on
how far out you went okay so that's what
radial means what does uh positive
definite mean well positive definite
just means that um if you take any M
Points X1 up to XM and you form a matrix
with all of the pair wise kernel values
a x i XJ then this
Matrix for any set of points um if you
plug in this kernel value for all pairs
in the IG entry this Matrix is going to
be positive definitely nice consequences
of having this all right so so far I've
just defined a problem
um I'll tell you very briefly why we
care about it but let me give you some
examples of kernels that people think
about um so you know one kernel that we
will talk about is the kosi
konel more generally there is the
soall
rational
that's just a gel whose expression is
given
by 1/ 1 + the distance between p and
Q rais to the power
of okay so all of these radial kernels
they only depend the value of kpq just
depends on the distance between PQ this
is the particular dependence here
another kernel that
[Applause]
uh we talk about is the so-called
student T
kernel and uh this expression is just
[Applause]
1/ okay so again it just depends on the
distance between p and Q all right so um
why do people care about these these
kind of Kernel problems turns out that
these things have many applications in
machine learning and statistics and data
analysis I'm actually not going to get
into the specific applications I'll tell
you one um what got me interested in in
these problems in the first place so I
was chatting with a colleague of mine um
shortly after arriving at Stanford
around 2015 bis he's in databases he
uses sketching methods and all the he
does and he was thinking about how do
you find outliers in data and um that
particular method is Method involved
basically just doing this colel
evaluation given a data set run this
procedure for a new Point treat this new
Point as a query and if this value turns
out to be high well you know it's kind
of like it's near the typical data set
point if the value turns out to beow as
far away from much of the data set so
that was the test that he was using to
determine whether or not there an outl
this just got me thinking about you know
how you would do this efficiently how
could you do this without actually
making a linear pass of the entire data
set because that's the obvious thing to
do right you want to evaluate this
quantity the obvious thing to do is to
just make a pass of the data set sum up
these these 10 quties can you avoid that
okay now by the way in non-parameter
statistics this kind of Kernel
evaluation procedure is pretty standard
the the idea is that if you're given a
samples from a distribution and you
don't want to make any assumptions about
this
distribution then one way to extend this
empirical distribution to the entire
space is to use a function like this so
essentially you smear the data smear
each point out over the entire space
okay
so and my initial thought was was um you
know maybe maybe some some methods
like sensitive hashing all all of the
nearest Naval literature could be
leveraged to solve this problem we'll
come back to that thought a little bit
later okay so that's how I got
introduced to these problems but you
know these these problems have been
around for a while okay so um you know I
mentioned nearest neighbor and you know
whenever we solve nearest neighbor we
don't really solve it exactly anymore we
we sort of approximate it and same with
all these kernel evaluation problems
we're going to be happy with getting
some kind of approximate value and the
approximate value um that we want is
something that's between one plusus
Epsilon so we're happy with any
estimate which is uh let me write it
like
this okay so um but it
works so we're happy with anything which
is
uh within 1 plusus
Epsilon of the actual
value question is can we do this
efficiently um how much space do we need
for for this data structure we're going
to preprocess the data and how quickly
can we answer the queries okay so this
is this is the question all right so um
you know even before computer scientists
or theoreticians started thinking about
this problem problem had been around for
a while and in the numerical analysis
literature um this is uh something which
is the domain of What's called the fast
multiple
[Applause]
me um so this is sort of a bread and
butter algorithm for people who do
computation numerical analysis exactly
for the kinds of computations where you
know let's say you have n bodies they
each exerting forces on each other you'd
like to figure out you know what's the
net force on each body in fact you want
to do this multiple times because maybe
you want to simulate the system how the
system evolve over time and so on so
forth so you're really very interested
in doing this very very
efficiently the first multiple method is
a classic method um
uh that's been developed for this
and typically the settings that people
concerned in practice in these settings
are threedimensional settings and bodies
or two- dimensional settings um in fact
if you take these methods and try to
extrapolate them to higher
Dimensions the dependence on Dimension
is pretty bad it's exponential in the
dimension roughly speaking the space
behaves like n to the power of
log n Epsilon to the^ of D
okay
and complexity also behaves like
log okay and very roughly speaking this
kind of exponential in D dependence is
because these methods rely on a
deterministic space partition
technique they take space they chop it
up in some
way and then um they do things like
well your query is here and look at all
this data that's sitting in this Square
turns out that there are good ways to
approximate the effect net effect of all
of these points on
this the chop space up at different
levels of resolution and so on so forth
and they do some kind of analysis like
this which leads to very very efficient
algorithms the way in which these
methods are usually quoted in in this
literature are their linear time but in
fact there is this exponential
dependence on D because they're not
really concerned with they were never
concerned with high dimensional setting
with high dimensional setting makes
sense when we start thinking about
machine learning and data analysis where
we really have high dimensional
points all right um
okay let me
uh that's all I'll say about about these
methods so as I mentioned the Genesis of
at least my work in this area was sort
of this chance conversation with a
colleague which got me thinking that
perhaps sampling based methods could be
used for this and so now there's a
there's actually a bunch of work on this
um let me just bundle it into one
so there was an initial paper that I
wrote with a student of mine paragus I
actually spoke about it here I think a
few years ago um so there's been a a few
papers after that and I'll summarize
what the net uh what we know about this
so I'm going to try a bunch of acronyms
here uh and maybe I'll mention some some
of the authors so uh this was worked by
with this student Paris
malakis later we teamed up with uh with
pendic uh and Au backers to do a little
Improvement on this we introduce the
notion of smooth kernels which I'll
actually get to in in a second
um it's also work by backers indic and
Wagner and then other work
by uh with Michael Calo naid MRI
[Applause]
and which
was
okay um the net result of the high level
idea of all of these methods is that
locality sensitive hashing data
structures which were trally designed
for which designed for nearest neighbor
search could also be used as data
structures for solving this problem and
why is that well you could think of
locality sensitive hashing data
structures as giving you a way to sample
points sample points in a distance
dependent way you're more likely to
sample points that are nearby the query
then points that are further away and
this kind of biased sampling is is in
some sense an important sample so if you
wanted to estimate the sum right you
could just independently sample queries
and figure out how many how many samples
do you need in order to get a good
estimate a clever way to do this would
be to say well maybe some terms in the
sum are pretty high and some terms are
pretty low I really should be sampling
the higher terms with higher
probability right if I could do that
then I can reduce the variance of this
estimator and maybe I get some that's
exactly what locality sensitive has
allows us to do it allows us to estimate
this quantity by giving a higher
probability to exactly the terms in the
data set P that have a higher
contribution now all this has to be
analyzed but that's that's basically the
gist of of the idea um and very roughly
speaking you know in the very first
paper that we had on this we showed that
um you could do okay so first of all let
me let me tell you what the Benchmark is
so if you're going to do random sampling
first you should ask what happens if you
just random sample a data set and try to
estimate that qu okay so the
Benchmark is just
uniform and if you did
that then the number of queries that you
need is the the number of samples that
you need is order of d ided
by Epsilon
s
okay all right so this is the amount of
time that you would take um and what we
showed initially and this has been
improved
since was that by using locality
sensitive hashing ideas this can be
improved
to Epsilon
s square root
of I didn't actually explain what mu is
so let me explain what mu is um all of
these results are going to be
parameterized by
mu so mu is
just the
value
[Applause]
sotion sorry correct value the correct
value div by n and let me just uh
mention one more thing I'm going to make
an assumption here throughout that all
of my kernel
values
are
[Applause]
uh between 0er and one okay so it's all
normalized everything is between 0 and
one the maximum value is n mu is just
telling you what fraction of this
maximum
value
so I Define this to be the
sum but here I'm actually sorry this is
too
low you know this
stuff okay so um I questions so the fast
multiple method do they have dependence
hiden also to the correct value the max
that new appears also somewhere in this
yeah yeah so actually um the fast
multile me as far as I remember and
actually I I uh it's a good thing that I
have my co-authors in the audience
because I'm going to lean on them to
answer all the difficult question um
these produce additive errors as far as
I know so I'm being a little bit um they
are not one plus Epsilon times the it
is
I think so but I'm not sure do do you
guys
[Applause]
know let me write that down Michael
says okay let me just put that in
quotes Okay so the guarante is a little
bit different not quite
okay questions about
this all right so what was the main
point of this work the main point of
this work and this is not the last word
by the way that we you know this this
got improved a little bit I won't I
won't say exactly what it was but the
main point was if this is the B if this
is The Benchmark can we improve the
dependence on mu and turns out that you
can you can actually improve the
dependence on to square root mu in the
in the first work and then later we
improved it to
Mu
[Applause]
the other question you could ask is what
about the Epsilon
dependence so the Epsilon dependence is
Epsilon squar it's quadratic in
epsilon and natural question is is that
the best thing possible okay so we'll
come to that question because that's
actually going to be the topic of much
of the topic of today all
right okay any
questions okay let me leave this here
since this is the problem definition
we're not going to need the actual
kernels here so I'm going to raisee that
and you all know what approximate means
[Applause]
so
okay
um there's a there's this particular
class of kernels that I'll be talking
about so called Smooth
con so SP was defined uh in this paper
by
[Applause]
[Music]
backers
um and roughly speaking these are
kernels that decay polom with this okay
I didn't Define the gaussian kernel but
if you think of the expression for
gaussian it drops off exponentially with
distance these kernels are those that
drop off polom with mid distance and it
turns out that for these smooth kernels
you can actually get a poly log
[Applause]
dependence okay so here these methods
that I mentioned before get an improved
dependence on mu but in fact if the
kernel has even more structure has this
polinomial drop off then you get a poly
log one over polylog 1 over mu
dependence the space complexity becomes
roughly n poly
log Epsilon squ and the query
time poly log
okay so all we did was again improve the
dependence on on mu we didn't change the
dependence on
Epsilon right now in some sense this
dependence on Epsilon this quadratic
dependence on Epsilon is inherent in any
sampling based approach if you think
about sampling just the basic sampling
approach you have to analyze the VAR of
the estimator use CHS and equality
that's exactly where this quadratic
dependence on Epsilon is
coming now in numerical
analysis you know in cases where this 1
/ Epsilon squ
dependence is uh prohibitively High
there's a certain class of methods that
they call
quasi I didn't know this term but I have
to thank my co-author Michael calov for
introducing to this term actually
introducing
both um so what quasa mtic Caro methods
are are are methods that are based on
discrepancy
[Applause]
Theory and if this sounds like a bunch
of new jargon I'll hopefully try to
deconstruct and explain what
so what what's the main idea the main
idea is instead of actually random
sampling what we're going to do is we're
going
to produce uh a random like set of
points so we're going to produce a
sample but not by random sampling but it
will have random like properties in fact
it will have better than random like
properties okay that's that's the
premise um Okay
so this approach this discrepancy based
approach um was actually applied by
Phillips and Tha in a
paper okay and what they were trying to
do was to
get small cor
sets for
thisal evaluation problem or colel
density estimation problem okay and I'll
say a little bit more about how this
works but let me give you a sort of a
high level
idea idea is let's do the following you
know I said sample a bunch of points at
random let's think of the sampling
happening in
phases let's first subsample half the
points and then after that we'll
subsample further and further and
further till we get down to the sample
size that we want okay so each of these
subsamplings each time we go down by
factor of half
view this subsample as being obtained
from a random
coloring imagine assigning colors plus
one minus
one in some clever way okay and now um
we'll analyze the properties of this
coloring and from that we'll get some
guarantees on the um on the colal
density problem
that's a very very high level but I'm
going to get to you I'm going to give
you some more details all right um it
turns out that uh there's a beautiful
theorem
[Applause]
of which promises linear
discrepancy at this point this doesn't
make any sense let me so don't worry
about it there's a certain Comal
quantity called discrepancy and there's
a beautiful theorem that actually gives
us some good properties for this
quantity using this theorem what
Phillips and Tai were able to do was
they were able to get Space which
is polinomial in D divide by Epsilon mu
and the query
time which
is polinomial m d
/
Epsilon and
notice forget about the MU
dependence sorry notep Square yes that's
the that's the key point the key point
is that they got a one over Epsilon
dependence instead of the 1/ Epsilon squ
dep okay so now the two classes of
methods sampling B methods which don't
don't fix the Epsilon problem they gave
you one/ Epsilon Square dependence but
they get you better dependence on you
and then there are these discrepancy
based
approaches which don't bother about the
new dependence but get you better
dependence
on and the main question that motivated
our work was can we get the best of both
worlds okay can we get the best of both
worlds for these smooth
kernels where um we're able to get poly
log 1/ mu but with a bad dependence on
Epsilon we're also able to get one
Epsilon dependence but with a bad
dependence on
mu okay so is the setup
[Applause]
clear I'm going to raisee the problem
now because I think you all know it
[Music]
um so this is um work with
the Michael
galov and Eric wi Garden who both in the
audience will appear
[Applause]
at
right okay um so what we show roughly is
that we can get polylog 1 over mu
dependence with linear in epsilon linear
in one over Epsilon because we can get
best of both world with some caveats
which I'll explain in a
second all right so first I should I
should tell you technically what what is
a smooth function so this is what smooth
function we don't actually need the
definition
but just just for
completeness so if you have a kernel
I'll say that this kernel
is there are two parameters and l
t smooth if it satisfies the following
okay if you have P1 and P2 in some query
q the main question is um what can I say
about the kernel value
for P1 and Q Rel with the kernel value
for P2 and Q and actually I'm going to
look at um both of these quantities
this and its inverse and ask how large
can these ratios
[Applause]
get okay and for a smooth
Kel these things depend on the distances
between points in the following way
[Applause]
so
and it's
[Music]
inverse so this
quantity time some proportionality
constant so if a kernel is LT smooth
then it has this kind of
this is what I mean by drops of polom
that's formal
definition
[Music]
right okay so
um what's the main
result the main result that we are able
to show is that for such kernels kernels
that have this kind of property um we
can
achieve
space um which
is it's a slightly ugly expression let
me write it down
[Applause]
the
time is the same thing without the
N
okay so we can get a 1 plus Epsilon
approximation with this kind of
parameters okay
so what's the main main point the main
point is that we got a dependence on log
1 / mu instead of mu we got a dependence
which is linear in one/ epsilon instead
of quadratic in one okay there are some
other additional ugly factors that we
got along the way um some maybe you can
eliminate some see harder um so one
factor that we have is this aspect ratio
five which I did not Define five is just
the
aspect ratio minimum maximum distance to
minimum distance
okay all right um how how am I doing on
time okay so let me give you a flavor of
how these techniques
work so in order to give you a flavor
what I'm going to do is
um I'll do this I'll I'll try to give
you
a view of this
result because it will give me a way to
talk about how exactly discrepancy comes
in okay so
um okay so what I want to do is I want
to tell you why is this quantity
discrepancy a useful quantity to think
about if you wanted to do this kernel
density
estimate okay all right so I said you're
going to think of sampling the data as
repeatedly subsampling and each
subsampling step can be thought of
as a coloring of the data into two sets
plus one and minus
one so if you think about the
following think of a coloring which
assigns to every point
minus one and one and let's think of e
Prime as those
points that get
assigned for
one okay what we'd like to do is the
following we want to
find a coloring
Kai of P
such
that if you look at the average k
p for all the
points
in
right minus the average over just the
points that are in P
[Applause]
Prime
[Music]
I want the average of the entire set to
be close to the average over P Prime
which is about half the set okay I would
like for this to be less than equal to
Epsilon
[Applause]
muing I'm not I'm not
uh but P Prime is going to be if this
was a if this is random coloring the
expected size of P Prime will be
half
okay you want this for um any cu or for
yes correct so this is not not just for
this one Cube because that would be very
easy to do I want this to hold for all
queries Q okay so I want this quantity
to be less than Epsilon time mu for all
queries Q right if I could do this then
I just do this repeatedly I'm going to
then repeatedly subsample and subsample
and subsample till I get down to the
right size okay now you can analyze this
by using random colorings at every stage
okay um and the kind of analysis that
you would do will actually recreate the
bound that you get from
CH the trouble is that there is some um
you know if you if you do random
sampling it's harder to control this
difference okay there's a better way to
control difference via these methods
called discrepancy so this quantity the
left hand side is just the sum
over the points in the set where I
assigned color
[Applause]
one two the points in the set where
assigned color minus
one
[Applause]
okay this is this is why it's called
discrepancy it's a difference between
the plus ones and the minus
ones there's a suite of techniques that
show how to achieve small discrepancy
small value this is exactly what you
need to implement the subsampling
procedure instead of random sampling
what you should do is you should just
use low discrepancy colorings
okay so that's exactly what Phil lips
and ta do they they combine this with uh
with low discrepancy
colorings now can I ask something about
the
inition said that all the idea is to
achieve someh to do important something
and keep the ones that they have higher
value can you connect why we need the
discrepancy to be low so now we're not
we're not doing that at all okay so that
that was that was a random sampling
approach right where um yes we're we're
doing this important sampling and
sampling the things with higher value
with higher
probability now I'm actually just giving
you a little more insight into how the
discrepancy based methods why
discrepancy is even useful why does it
make sense think called discrepancy does
it make sense okay so set that intuition
aside for now we're not actually using
that intuition at all okay all
right so how am I
doing minutes okay very very quick
um
so what do you
need for this discrepancy to work so
um so banasik theorum says that this
quantity
which is the
discrepancy uh
ofing
Kai on the data set p with respect to Q
This is less than equal
to order
of the gamma 2
Norm of this kernel Matrix okay now this
this sounds like a bunch of jargon but
but it's actually just the
following um let's take this kernel
Matrix
K it's positive
definite right this means that there is
an embedding of this kernel Matrix such
that um the kernel value for x Comm Y is
equal to the inner product between 5x
and
[Applause]
5 okay what's the gamma 2 Norm of this
Matrix the gamma 2 Norm of this
Matrix is just the maximum of the 5x
Norms times the maximum of the pi
[Applause]
y okay now um in order to for Philips
and Tai in order to get their result
what they did was they said great let's
do this let's apply Bic theorem let's
apply the discrepancy bounds that you
get from that in here and in order to
get a they need a they need a gamma 2
Norm estimate they said well this is a
kernel Matrix also the kernel values are
at most one so in fact there is an
embedding such that each of these are at
most unit vectors each everything is at
most a unit Vector so in fact the gamma
Norm is bounded up above by one that's
the main idea right okay so in Just 2
minutes let me say one main idea that
was helpful for
us what we realized is that if you have
a smooth kernel and if you have a
certain geometric condition so there's
two situations one is you have a query
that's sitting inside this ball here and
then the rest of the r side is outside
this ball or you have a query which is
sitting outside this ball and the entire
data set is sitting inside you have some
sort of geometric separation Condition
it's kind of similar to the kind of
conditions that are used in Fast
multiple method you have either this or
this then if you look at this kernel
Matrix it turns out that you can get a
much better bound on the gamma to nor
okay and how do you do that
um so roughly speaking you can write out
um sort of the expansion of look at the
llas transform write out the expansion
of the kernel that gives you a natural
embedding
okay tweak the embedding a little bit to
make sure that these points which have
small Norm get a little bit of a boost
and these points that have that have
larger Norm actually get a boost in the
negative
Direction so you can you you can adjust
these embeddings so that you change the
factors term by term the product Still
Remains the Same so this condition still
holds right but if you went inside the
dimensions the individual Dimensions we
changed those Dimensions so that these
things here become a little bit bigger
these things outside get a little bit
smaller and amazingly this kind of thing
can be arranged so that you get a much
better bound on the
gamma okay so this is the main idea now
of course our data set doesn't satisfy
this condition right it's not like this
at all so what we have to do is we have
to do a randomized partitioning of the
data by carving out L2
balls okay um and using this idea we
ensure that we're
always working on portions of the data
set that satisfy either this condition
or this I'm sort of hiding a lot of
details under the carpet that's the main
idea yeah so in this argument like where
do you use the fact that you have a
Smooths yeah good so I didn't actually
get into enough of the detail in order
to be able to to say that but um roughly
speaking when you look at the the error
that you get you have to look at the
ratio of the error to the value of the
colel okay so you need to know how much
error did you introduce and what's the
value of the kernel you want that ratio
to be at
so in that
calculation uh we really use the fact
that we have a smooth
G because what's what's actually
happening is we're operating on the data
where the data is all sitting inside a
big ball and
outside a tiny ball inside there's
a another ball here another W here what
we know is
that let's say our query is sitting in
here a data set is sitting in
here now the when you calculate the
value of the error relative to the value
of the kernel it's some function of
these four
radi okay and in that calculation the
fact that the kernel is a smooth kernel
comes in it's actually
[Applause]
useful
here maybe a couple a couple questions
um actually I had a question first which
is so what I didn't understand
definition of gamma 2K so what domains
are X and Y being taken from so I just
said um yeah I was I was not being very
specific so uh you know X are these guys
y's are these
guys so they really the same domain we
have this kernel we we we write it out
as as the inner product there a gram
Matrix so think of it like this what
does it mean for a colel to be positive
Su definite are the rows there just
capital
P I guess the rows are just the points
yes yes yes so why why isn't this just
the square of it's the square it's a
square in this case but what we do is we
treat things a little bit differently
because when we write out this thing
we're going to look at the possible
queries as one dimension and the data
set points as the other dimension
okay and we're going to treat them
differently so it's actually relevant
for us that we treat x's and
[Applause]
y's more
questions then let's thank him again and
B
up